welcome back to cbs mornings the u.s and
its allies promised the most damaging
financial sanctions yet in response to
russia's full-scale invasion of ukraine
the capital kiev and other ukrainian
cities have been hit by air and missile
strikes over the past several hours and
ground troops are crossing the border
president biden calls it an unprovoked
and unjustified attack by russian
military forces later today he is
expected to announce further
consequences the u.s has deployed a
limited number of additional troops to
nato countries but the president has
repeatedly made it clear he will not
send any u.s troops into ukraine david
martin is at the pentagon david good
morning what can you tell us about the
latest on the us's military response
well there are 5 000 paratroopers from
the 82nd airborne in poland
and their primary mission
is to go to the
polish border if needed to process
the
stream of refugees
trying to flee across the border from
ukraine as you can
imagine there's been a dramatic increase
in the number of people trying to cross
that border
by one estimate uh
five times as many as
before the attack
the 82nd would send paratroopers
up to the border stations to help polish
border
patrol guards process
people coming across the border and they
would also run facilities a little
further back from the border at
airfields where
refugees would be
housed and fed until they could figure
out where to go
from there
and david what kind of military support
can our military provide to the
ukrainians now that we're closer
well
the president has
been clear that
u.s troops are not going to go
into
the ukraine even
to rescue americans who are trapped
there uh so the the u.s role right now
is to
help with the flow of refugees both in
poland
and coming across ukraine's southern
border into
romania and then beyond that
it will be to
reinforce
nato we have something like 8 500 troops
on alert back here in the united states
ready to go to nato to reinforce that
eastern
flank
the other countries aren't being
threatened yet but you don't know where
this is going to go
exactly and now our troops are in the
region thank you or closer to where the
where this conflict is happening thank
you so much david